i think it was a you know the right
decision for you know roger hutton to
resign because um the politicians were
blaming him that he didn't you know take
the responsibility and the ownership to
persuade the other board members that a
cultural change needs to take place and
then when he did ask for help from the
ecb they um apparently declined you know
to help him you know with these matters
at yorkshire so he obviously had no
choice he felt that it's too difficult
for him
to make any changes and he did the right
thing to resign i mean it goes deeper
than that though doesn't it i mean he
was brought in as a reformer
if you like just last year after all
these allegations were made so
uh clearly other members of the board
that he's leveled allegations against
today they should perhaps follow him
shouldn't they
well i think they're having an emergency
meeting today and
there's possibly two non-executive board
members may look to resign today who
were you know close um you know friends
of you know roger hutton and there's
also pressure on on the ceo michi arthur
i'm sorry and and also um the sorry mark
arthur and um martin moxen you know when
they face um you know the
the parliamentary hearing on november
the 16th it'll be interesting to see how
transparent they are you know clarity is
needed um during that uh you know
hearing and yorkshire must be really
honest about what really happened you
know during the time when azim rafiq was
a professional cricketer at the club
using the p word regarded in some
circles as banter it would seem
well i think that's completely you know
unacceptable and there needs to be a
clear understanding you know which words
are banter which words are racism you
know terms and and the p word is is
clearly a a racist you know um term and
it should be you know like that there
should be you know people are
are debating on why the reason if you're
a pakistani why can't we call you the p
word um like we call you know the
australian aussies or um britain people
brits you know it's just completely you
know unacceptable to even have that
debate you know you just cannot use the
p word as simple as that
have you experienced racism while you
were playing
no one ever used the p word you know
against me and um you know i i didn't
experience any any of this sort of
racism and
even when my time when i was at sussex
even in the england team
and and essex you know people would ask
me you know about my culture and embrace
that but what helped that was because
the likes of mushtaq ahmed was that
sussex a senior figure the club
understood diversity embracing you know
cultures and that's something that
yorkshire need to do if they're really
serious about you know understanding
what inclusivity means they need to have
a point a chairman of british asian and
descent and the like of you know lord
patel seems to be an ideal candidate
what harm has been done to yorkshire
county cricket club with this row given
the fact that these racism allegations
have been levelled but because
it seems to be intensified of course by
their handling or mishandling of what
has happened
well they avoided the issues with azim
rafiq it was clearly they didn't take
any of his allegations seriously they
gave insignificant concern about the
whole you know issue there and now um
they're in a position where they have to
be open and honest you know in a
parliamentary hearing where even boris
johnson has put pressure on the ecb to
deal with this matter and swiftly or
else you know the government would take
over and they will make the bigger
decisions so you know the ecb need to be
strong about their decisions and they
have been but they need to you know be
absolutely clear that yorkshire county
cricket club need to be embracing
diversity inclusivity we need to see
more british asian coaches coming
through the system but at the leadership
level in we make key decisions we need
to see british asians to be appointed in
in them roles to be stripped of
international matches look at headingly
world famous test ground is that a
sufficient punishment in your opinion
well look i think we have to wait and
see you know what happens after you know
the november the 16th and what decisions
um you know yorkshire look to make in
embracing a fresh start and if it's
adequate you know with the government um
with the likes of sajid javid and you
know the the parliamentary committee in
a meeting that they have then you know
ecb may allow them to have international
you know cricket backup headingly but
they need to show these changes because
at the moment if they don't show any
transparency you know the rumor would be
that people think maybe yorkshire county
cricket club is institutely racist
um and in your opinion as you were
mentioning there bringing somebody of of
asian descent to head up things uh
headingly that is the only way forward
is it
i i think that is the only option for
them and they saying the likes of you
know that the ex-chairman you know
calling grieves to come back but he was
there when azeem rafiq was there and
didn't you know deal with these issues
and if he does want to come back he
needs to he will have to face you know
parliamentary hearing why does he want
to come back and there'll be extra
questions asked about him i think is
that the simplest and the smoothest
option here is make lord patel um a
permanent chairman of yorkshire county
cricket club
this is uh presumably uh things like
this happen outside yorkshire too so
other clubs need to be scrutinized don't
they
well this is an opportunity for you know
anyone from the ethnic minorities played
professional cricket a british asian or
even you know a
british black cricketer to come through
and talk about it openly you know they
can contact the pc pca the ecb if they
need to speak you know to um you know
any of the sort of media companies and
they can go out and speak to them or
give an interview and be honest about
what allegations or racisms that they've
actually received or experienced because
i think the ecb you know are open to
hear their stories because they want to
you know embracing inclusivity you know
they they are they've committed to doing
you know uh other plans to develop urban
centers around you know there's the
cities where over 50 percent you know of
british asian popular population are are
in the cities based but they lack that
facility so ecb are trying to you know
help with that so they'll be open to any
sort of these kind of you know racial
allegations that
you know
other british you know asian cricketers
possibly have faced